guess what Kevin what today we are
drawing Pixar characters from from our
brain it's funny because the minute that
I heard it was Pixar everything blanks
out of my mind yeah yeah I mean you say
Pixar and it's like you know every kind
of scene Toy Story yeah I feel like I've
seen most Pixar movies as a kid your
character today is all Frederickson I
may have a distinct advantage I have a
t-shirt of him no okay he is complicated
can we met give us another one
nope okay um let's start the head yeah I
haven't watched this movie in a long
time so I really got to remember he's
got binoculars fries yeah I recall just
gonna rely on the cuteness factor again
if you do it wrong but you make it cute
sometimes it's okay it's just like
murder wait say that again
so hey Jun what's your favorite Pixar
movie that's a loaded question I mean I
really like ratatouille actually eat
yeah yeah it's really good ratatouille
is solid but I feel like it's not really
the one people pick when they talk about
their favorite my favorite Pixar movie
is really quali for me wall-e was like a
little preachy really I absolutely loved
it I watched it in all its it's like
this movie barely has any sound yeah and
it's like it's doing it for me do you
remember what Wally's purpose is to find
the vegetation no no to like squeeze
things and box yeah yeah so he's got
like a little trash compactor he's a
triangle right he's a square boy I think
he's a rhombus he has like underwear on
like he has like a barrel body and then
undies well cuz he's an action figure so
he has to have points of articulation
you need points of articulation he has
like three fingers right yeah no oh and
um and he has like a roach
yes that he keeps in his box did Toy
Story make you cry I don't think the
first Toy Story made me cry I think I
was a kid so I was probably like I don't
have emotions yet cried in the second
one super hard yeah the montage it's
just so sad what's what's keeping the
binoculars on the box
yeah that's why is it just like there's
some like mechanism that causes the that
lets the eyes curl a little bit oh yeah
like kind of em oh yeah this is feeling
a lot harder than I thought
no not we got this I'm feeling good
about this pose I'm feeling good about
the construction and now it's just the
details it's just where it all falls
apart yes this is like looking more like
grunkle Stan from gravity falls no
square men oh you know what I remember
that's a really weird detail he has the
swirl on his chin Oh does he remember he
or is it does he now that you're
questioning no I'm not sure no he very
well may I just I don't feel like I
tricked you ah yeah this work gets tough
man I don't like 100 all robots like a
whole lot right now I'm just drawing
binoculars on a box yeah he doesn't have
hair right the hair is so hard to
remember I'm just improvising he has
that thing that astronauts right it's
over his head oh yeah yeah good thing
good thing okay he has like a battery
schematic on them right I mean like to
let you know how much energy energy yes
yeah we yeah he's got the Sun thing I
can't remember this character from the
knees down but I know he has like army
tank wheels kind of yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah he's got like tank treads feel like
he's got like like his his legs are kind
of like bent under him from said I don't
know what to call these types of feet
he's like boom feet so he has boots I'm
like so hesitant to commit to any
details down I think maybe we should
stop trying
oh we have to keep going to infinity and
beyond Jackie Jackie come back whoo I
got a good little detail do you remember
he has like a little laser thing in
between and that's how he cuts things oh
I'd like a little laser diet I didn't
know that yeah that doesn't look right
but you know Jackie come on how you
doing Jason I think I'm almost there you
know say I drew a Wally like substance a
holy like okay time to color all right
yeah very dull but I'm kind of making
him right I think you're gonna do way
better at this than me because I'm
really not confident I'm giving him blue
gloves even though I'm gonna give him
some highlights and like chrome
highlights you're already on highlights
yeah get on my level I feel like there's
so much wrong with this I'm just kind of
making it up and hopefully it looks okay
okay I think that's uh as far as I'm
gonna get I think I did super good
I don't remember ever drawing Wally but
he's like he's pretty simple like if you
can draw a couple of inanimate objects I
think you're like already 90% of the way
there uh-huh
so I think I captured this essence but I
kind of made him into more of a
commitment
yeah I I think I got his essence as well
but I'm sure all of the details are
wrong yeah I think once I see what he
looks like I'm gonna feel like just a
just a big old fool yeah can't wait to
reveal this one
oh yeah oh man
yours looks a little sinister yeah oh my
god the shade you got him like way
closer than I did your car looks like he
has had enough of business
screw you Corporate America just looking
at yours I can tell you what's wrong
with mine oh you got the the ear
covering okay you got the three colored
things on yeah the thing I remember the
most for some reason is those buttons
yeah I would say I think you got his
legs pretty good cuz now now that I see
it I remember like the lines on his boot
the boots
yeah goofy yeah Jackie I think you're
gonna be surprised with how well you did
okay I hope so I mean a much more
colorful like leg you got the drab color
palette much more oh and I forgot he's
got a little he's such a complicated
character like toy stuff yeah like he
has like the shines yes the screw holes
in his legs
yeah even like the little air vents on
his forearms and like how are you
supposed to remember that it's too much
I have one brain I think it's like an
iconic look it's made up of really
simple shapes yeah so like works I think
we both know what Wadley looks like in
our head yeah both of them you could
clearly look at them and say that's
Wally yeah we made a lot of mistakes
this time around we did but you know
what
you don't improve as a person without
making mistakes positivity Jackie PMA
positive mental attitude thank you thank
you
[Music]